[Applaudissements]
je me présente pas bien de l'être
producteurs voilà il fait partie de
cette équipe d'uzès et cambrai
présentation alors il va l'outil sais
pas ce qu'il va vivre devrait sortir
regardez la ville y aller en pleurant
parce qu'ils travaillent côte à côte sur
un bisou à l'est fait une victime qui
n'en profitez pas non plus des adieux
pour commencer à me tromper tout le
monde vous savez ce qu'est le producteur
donc on peut pas non plus y passer toute
l'émission mais je voulais qu 10e timo
maintenant peut-être à vos équipes très
rapide à cyril à qui vous voulez c'est
votre moment pour vous dire eh bah je
vais pas mourir c'est non merci à tous
merci d'avoir été là j'ai un petit peu
et je vais pas pleurer je vais parce que
la télé c'est que de la télé est donc
merci a tous voila de m'avoir soutenu et
d'avoir été là pendant ces mois qui
était des fois un peu sport on arrive
[Applaudissements]
si plus